this danish couple has booked a holiday
apartment for a short trip to berlin
it's 65 square meters and it has one
bedroom
manages it for the owner it's a service
that's in big demand
more and more residents of popular
tourist destinations are renting their
private flats and creating a whole new
market dishes and glasses you find here
we prefer uh apartments from
instead of a hotel
it's more private hello what time do you
expect us the couple is paying 286 euros
for four nights if the apartment is
booked solid it can bring in about 2 000
euros a month a tidy profit for the
owner perfect thank you very much resign
for you if you have paid
the owner lives in tel aviv we also have
owners in greece italy france and many
in germany but very few who live in
berlin
most only come here on vacation
these apartments are in berlin's trendy
friedrichshain district they were
converted into condominiums and sold the
new owners can make almost three times
the money taking in tourists that they'd
make from rent-paying tenants
the booming market is served by internet
portals like nine flats germany's
biggest offering more than a hundred
thousand holiday apartments and rooms
many of them are in cities like london
and new york
last year nine flats tripled its annual
sales
but many city residents are afraid the
trend will make apartments even harder
to come by nine flats doesn't think so
in berlin berlin has a shortage of about
40 000 apartments
all the portals combined offer something
like 2500 apartments
if private holiday flats were to be
prohibited
maybe 350 or at most 400 more apartments
would be available for normal renters
none of the others have ever even been
available on the market anyway
but other estimates put the number of
holiday apartments at closer to 14 000
and growing steadily and many of them
aren't legally registered
of course you can't say that anyone
ought to be allowed to do this
it depends on the rental agreement or if
it's a condo um
but if someone is making money with it
then of course they need to have a
commercial license and they need to pay
taxes
berlin registers nearly 25 million
overnight stays a year
holiday flats close to the city center
are in high demand
like these socialist era apartments near
the reichstag nearly one out of three
flats here is being rented out to guests
sometimes they're rented to entire tour
groups coming here on holiday
but the permanent residents are
beginning to complain about the noise
i've called the police many times
because these groups carry on until two
or three in the morning
you'd think they'd get tired or just
fall over from so much boozing but no
they just keep going
so i don't have any choice but to call
the police
now the berlin city government is
considering prohibiting the private
holiday apartments
that would put the service center and
others like it out of business and
eliminate the jobs
your
is hoping for a compromise
a regulated spectrum of options would be
far better than a complete ban
the berlin senate is set to vote on the
so-called misappropriation of living
space in the coming weeks